c'è nessuno
[Musica]
tutti si sono fatti che cosa che cosa ci
fai qui nascosta pistoncino no grazie io
veramente sto cercando gli ingredienti
slime se mi puoi dire dove li hai
nascosti così io vado a cercarli io sono
sono nascosti che dove sono dimmi che
comparano ridotti la paura
[Musica]
facebook o proprio migliore
bentornati oggi nuova challenge servono
a trovare gli ingredienti islands
considera it pennywise il pagliaccio
lasciato mi piace se volete una seconda
parte con il pagliaccio di questo video
raggiunge i 15 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche una seconda parte ma solo se
riesco a sopravvivere oggi
ok andiamo
ok ragazzi sono in camera
aiutatemi anche voi a cercare gli
ingredienti questo è uno delle challenge
che mi inquieta più di tutte per kate è
veramente pauroso perché ci sono dei
palloncini rossi lassù guardate
tu devi essere stato qua o no che cosa
farà foto qua ha detto che li ha
nascosti lui quindi sicuramente è stato
in tutta la casa
il pensiero che lui sia stato come i
primi brividi
guardate si sono tipo iii palloncini
rossi lassù anche se non non non sa
salgono in aria
strano comunque non mi fido preferisco
non toccarli e lasciarli lei
cerchiamo assieme qua non mi sembra di
vedere niente
purtroppo ho anche paura di di offrire
un arma dico non so mi sembra che possa
spuntare fuori da ovunque anche per chi
vive nelle tubature
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua
non c'è niente
questo voglia dire che devo lasciare
questa stanza ma non mi sembra che ci
sia niente ma c'è un palloncino o paure
ricontrollare assist in là nelle scale
sicuramente una trappola
sicuramente c'è lì lui lì altrimenti non
si spiega come sistema del pallone
signori io non rischio non avvicinarmi
ma sentiamo ma quale un'altra palloncino
ma come è possibile non può essere i due
posti contemporaneamente vero che
andiamo chiamo
ho paura che spunti da un momento
all'altro piano ma non c'è niente qua
mancano sia sotto il letto
possibile non c entra da dentro penso
che cosa cortile allora forse in una
trappola provare a prendere il
palloncino che serve un po di paura di
toccarlo incastonato in te stesso sul
letto a spatola inutile forse gli
ingredienti sono attaccata ai palloncini
estremo che mi voglia aiutare in questo
modo a trovarli fantastico ragazzi ho
già trovato lo spunto non so cosa fare
in questo palloncino
spero che non richiami la sua attenzione
ora fa dovevo portare la spatola in
studio mi sono spaventata e rabbia virus
la bozza qua non penso che tu riesca a
prenderlo no ok ti amo vedere che in
creta integerrimo
speriamo che sia una colla con sistema
giacomo svantaggiati ma se devo dire
andata poi invece faccio finita
resta tier 1 1 che cos'è la guerra la
chiave fare fino ai figli
ok forse andato via ragazzi ci è mancato
ma io pensavo che ai palloncini fossero
legati agli ingredienti che devo trovare
come in questo ma sono stata molto
stupida ingenua perché è ovvio che lui
non mi vuole aiutare in nessun modo
vuole soltanto prendermi quindi lui ha
settato una trappola e cioè dove ci sono
i palloncini ci sono gli ingredienti ma
dove ci sono i palloncini c'è anche lui
quindi vuol dire che io non saprò mai se
potrò prendere l'ingrediente se quindi
troverò l'ingrediente col palloncino o
troverò lui
in ogni caso dobbiamo continuare la
challenge altrimenti non sparirà mai di
capire quale potrebbe essere un suo
punto debole è molto difficile perché è
uno dei cattivi più forti che siano mai
esistiti
ti amo sei ancora
non c'è più
[Applauso]
ma cos'altro si è spenta una luce a dire
che è passato di qui vediamo se c'è
qualcosa fossero piano di sopra con
prestito sopra cercare di completare
questa legge
guardate ciao marcelo lo vedete quindi
vuol dire che c'è lui come ingrediente
che ti fa male da questa chiaro
guardate
c'è già raggiunto la gente ci sono gen
comunque sembra contenta non si stira
sua sola della società
per lei no
perché contenuto al centro si esprimesse
la miccia per svegliarmi innanzitutto
togliamo questo palloncino
lascio andare prendiamo lasciato per la
soluzione vivo
[Musica]
11 59 mia ti manderò
1 del rosso di capelli
l'ho scampata per un paio anche questa
forza ma almeno mancano solo due cose il
bicarbonato e la colla
ho come l'impressione che saranno
difficilissime da prendere ma proprio ok
andiamo dobbiamo sbrigarci non si è
ancora qua dietro
[Musica]
guardate
il fortunato è così vicino e così
facilmente
non lo so ma sicuramente non si può
nascondere d'angelo a trento si pone
[Musica]
vabbè lasciamo andare vicino grazie
anche più carbonato più viva
mi manca solo la colla una fantastica
sì perché ho la soluzione parlanti la
ciotola la spatola si incazzano la colla
cantate cosa succede
quando persone perché un palloncino andò
a catturare umano forse ne ha portato
anche lui la tua quarto pure ora di che
cosa vetro qua che cosa devo fare
non so se anche lui acqua ascolto da
quale parte perché mi è arrivato questo
barboncino forse perché vuole
individuarmi più facilmente
[Musica]
roma la testa dopo aver preso una botta
non ho ancora trovato la colla quindi
posso completare la challenge ficcano la
troppo capisco forse vuol dire che la
colla in mezzo a una di queste milioni
di scatole non farò mai quali mezzo ci
sono troppe cose guardate avete sentito
faccia mentre diventa sempre più
inquietante c'è niente che te lo fa se a
questa porta sono sicura che lui infatti
altro non so perché una strana
sensazione
vediamo ovviamente è chiuso a chiave
dovrò iniziare la ricerca quale ora
milioni di scatole cinesi
vediamo un po se questa cosa si diranno
soffrono mai a trovare una cosa così
piccola come la colla
insomma così tante scarpe niente
buttarmi l'alzo guardate laggiù c'è una
sorta di tunnel nero
ora che lui sarà la storia possa stare
qua aspettare il guardare troppo ma non
voglio andare in quel tunnel nero
guardate se un martello
forse romperà qualcosa con questo
martello sotto può difendermi con questo
martello mi sembra troppo piccolo per
riuscire a completare lo slime poi
scomparirà quindi baita dove può essere
una colla pensiamoci bene assieme
mi fido nelle tubature quindi immagino
che gli piace l'acqua quindi forse deve
essere qualcosa a che fare con l'acqua o
forse col fuoco ha bisogno a bruciarlo
mirato di gela
io provo ora a togliere il palloncino
del mio braccio evitiamo dove fa il
palloncino per il palloncino mi
indirizzerà verso la colla proviamo
sembra che stiamo vento ok qua che cosa
per dire che è qua qua dentro
non penso non ci sta non c'è niente qua
qua si sono delle società di tubature
non capisco questa siano ma meglio non
toccarle fatto non vederla prima
eccola palloncino stava invitando a
giusto e meritato 4
eccola è anche quella rossa
ovviamente c'è solo un piccolissimo
problema gli altri ingredienti sono
nella mia stanza nel mio studio non qua
quindi non posso fare non posso farlo
solo con la colla o per forza riuscire a
scappare da qua a parlare nella mia
stanza in qualche modo la porta è chiusa
non so che fare se nata un'idea forse
per fare in modo che lui apre la porta
chiti rock è cambiato idea e che quello
unirmi a lui andare con lui sì lui
aprire la porta pensando che che ho
cambiato idea e hiro asca però non so se
funzionerà questo piano è molto
rischioso ma è l'unico modo
proviamo a chiamarlo ma si chiama it
pennywise penso che sia penny wise dei
pennywise c'è nessuno volevo dirti che
ho cambiato idea voglio venire con te si
era rimasto fuori come ha fatto ma se io
vengo contempo momenti mi che lascerai
berlino in pace allora non mi interessa
preferisco sacrificarmi io per lui
ok però ho un ultimo desiderio prima di
essere mangiata voglio fare un'ultima
cosa
e vorrei che e tu rimani un momento in
posa con il palloncino così ti faccio
una foto una foto ricordo
perfetto allora allora io conto fino a 5
e uscirò di qui poi tu dovrai essere in
posa con il palloncino così io ti faccio
la foto e poi potrai mangiarmi va bene
l'aspetto momento devo ti hanno detto
che devo contare fino a 5 devo momento
prepararmi psicologicamente per farlo
devono per farmi per farti la foto
aspetta un momento che essi momento non
so se ce la farò
ok conto fino a 5 poi vado tu mettiti in
posa ok
una due tre bellissimo cosa stai
benissimo
dai
ma si capisce che ce lo porta a scappare
[Musica]
devo fare il possibile
ecco fatto estremo che non si sente che
nessun rumore
ora che spunti fuori all'improvviso da
qualche parte dall'armadio dal popolo
non lo so
mostrano questo silenzio mi dispiace
aver lasciato un berlino fuori ma se la
caverà
altrimenti avrei perso ancora non ci
posso credere che sono riuscita ad
imbrogliare la vicenda gli di mettersi
in posa essere partito questa strada
perché fa con la trasparenza e più
rapido ad hoc i boschi sembra proprio lo
slime di così il rosso è quasi pronto ma
non è che non sempre sul rumore non mi
abbia intrappolato qua dentro persona in
me pronto ma non c'è nessuna traccia di
paris
forse è già scomparsa possibile pronto
coinvolta anche questa volta non pensavo
che sarei mai riuscita a sopravvivere
questa legge è stata difficilissima
decisamente uno dei personaggi più
inquietanti in assoluto mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace se volete vedere un
altro episodio con it
magari non sarà trova gli ingredienti
slime ma qualcos'altro
scrivetemi anche dei commenti quale
volete che siano i prossimi personaggi
orafi la sua 4 castellini su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione